er bereitet das abendessen für die ganze
familie vor es gibt reis mit bohnen dazu
eine suppe und frischen salat fleisch
gehört doch eigentlich auch zu einem
türkischen essen dazu takanashi nur
lachen und den kopf schütteln
fleisch gibt es nur von einem festtag
zum anderen das kannst du dir schon gar
nicht mehr leisten bei den preisen
wieder noch
sieben oder acht prozent inflation wie
aktuell in deutschland davon können sie
hier in der türkei nur träumen um das
zehnfache umfasst 79 prozent sind die
preise binnen jahresfrist gestiegen
offiziell ökonomen sagen es sei noch
viel mehr wo soll das noch hinführen
alles ist so teuer geworden die energie
die mieten die lebensmittel
mein vater konnte mit einem gehalt seine
zwölf kinder ohne weiteres ernähren und
das war damals auch nur mindestlohn
heutzutage kann man nicht mal ein kind
mit dem gehalt ernähren wieso ist das so
warum sind wir in dieser lage
war idee ist bereits verheiratet hat
eine tochter für ihren bruder kann der
kommt das überhaupt nicht in frage eine
hochzeit kostet ein vermögen viele
monatslöhne
kannst du vergessen die familie der
braut möchte drei bis vier gold am reife
als mitgift ich habe beim juwelier
gefragt 90.000 lehrer wie soll ich mir
das leisten können wie soll ich da
heiraten kinder kriegen gar nicht zu
denken
zu acht leben sie in dem kleinen haus in
einem ärmeren viertel von istanbul
teilen sich drei zimmer der vater und
einige geschwister sind noch unterwegs
die eltern bekommen eine kleine rente
kadir arbeitet als automechaniker
verdient mindestlohn nur er und einer
seiner brüder bringen geld mit nach
hause
wie dieser familie geht es so fielen in
der türkei zum leben zu wenig zum
sterben zu viel rund 60 prozent aller
beschäftigten arbeiten im
niedriglohnsektor viele zum mindestlohn
den hat die regierung gerade angehoben
zum zweiten mal in diesem jahr auf jetzt
5500 lira rund 310 euro führt er macht
das kaum einen unterschied
es hat nichts gebracht denn gleich
danach sind die preise für die güter
auch gestiegen egal wohin du schaust
alles ist wieder teurer geworden das
reicht hinten und vorne nicht
kommendes jahr wird gewählt erdogan muss
um seine macht bangen für ihn zählt nur
eines die wirtschaft wachstum um jeden
preis lag die inflation auch davonrennen
auf geheiß des präsidentenpalasts
bleiben die zinsen niedrig hauptsache
die wirtschaft floriert in
erster linie haben wir die produktion in
allen bereichen unterstützt damit die
räder nicht zum stillstand kommen und
die beschäftigung nicht zurückgeht
30,5 millionen menschen sind derzeit
beschäftigt die exportzahlen bewegen
sich um die 250 milliarden dollar das
sind die beweise für unsere bemühungen
die nebenwirkungen sind enorm wenige
profitieren viele leiden die zentralbank
müsste eigentlich die zinsen drastisch
erhöhen um den preisauftrieb zu bremsen
sagt die ökonomen island der igmg der
präsident sehe aber in den zinsen selbst
die wurzel allen übels
sie machen ein experiment inflation
reduzieren mit niedrigen zinsen anstatt
sie zu erhöhen der gedanke dabei ist die
konjunktur anzukurbeln das wachstum zu
erhöhen aber die logik der wirtschaft
funktioniert so nicht
wir können nicht überleben so heißt eine
initiative die ph nur janneck mit
aufgebaut hat er studiert
ingenieurswesen und schreibt gerade
seine doktorarbeit das ziel der
initiative
sie wollen den menschen die augen öffnen
zeigen dass es anderen genauso geht wie
ihnen sondern die menschen fühlen sich
allein gelassen mit ihren problemen
schlimm genug dass sie nicht mehr wissen
wie sie ihr leben bestreiten sollen sie
ziehen sich auch immer mehr zurück er
ist die pandemie und nun dass das ist
nicht einfach
sie alle können kaum ihre rechnungen
bezahlen so gehen sie auf die straße
protestieren gegen die unkontrolliert
steigenden lebenshaltungskosten staaten
unterschriftenaktionen gegen die
mietpreise nicht einfach in einem land
in dem die staatsmacht allgegenwärtig
ist doch sie nennen die dinge beim namen
als die strompreise in die höhe
geschnellt sind haben wir die menschen
darüber aufgeklärt dass strom der 30
cent kostet dem endverbraucher für 210
cent in rechnung gestellt wird siebenmal
mehr als er eigentlich zahlen müssen und
wer steckt sich das in die tasche die
energiekonzerne
stromkonzerne wieder verstaatlichen mehr
sozialwohnungen bauern mehr unterstützen
ihrer hauptforderungen dass sie erfüllt
werden unwahrscheinlich
der präsident hat anderes im sinn er
nutzt die außenpolitische bühne um sich
als starker führer zu präsentieren und
lenkt so von den problemen vor der
eigenen haustür ab der beitritt von
schweden und finnland in die nato nichts
geht ohne erde
[Musik]
in syrien lässt er immer wieder die
muskeln spielen hat neue offensiven im
norden des landes gegen die bewaffnete
kurden miliz ttg angekündigt
und bei den blockierten getreide
exporten aus der ukraine mit die türkei
auch mit versucht zu vermitteln und will
transporte übernehmen sobald es denn
geht
all das interessiert kg und seine
familie gerade nicht die regierung solle
endlich an menschen wie sie denken eine
wirkliche perspektive die sieht er für
sich in der türkei aber nicht mehr wer
kann verlässt das land
bei der ersten möglichkeit die sich mir
bietet will ich hier weg
im moment bin ich hier gefangen aber ich
will weg hier nach england nach
deutschland oder nach frankreich
hauptsache weg von hier ist mir ganz
egal wohin la france
bis zu den wahlen im kommenden jahr wird
sich wohl nichts ändern alle gehen davon
aus dass die preise noch weiter steigen
werden wo soll das nur hinführen das
fragen sie sich jeden tag
[Applaus]
[Musik]